But in Utah, we have a great place to practice, we have great scenery, but we also have GVHD.
We have not ridden that yet, so it's not perfect.
But I wanted to just go over a project that was initiated by an observation of some of our nurse practitioners
and our faculty that looked at latitude GVHD and its onset in patients.
As background, Dr. Marta Arora at the University of Minnesota has already described this in the past as early as 2016 and even before,
where they looked at incidents in a fairly large amount of patients, 511 people,
and saw that the varieties of GVHD that are out there, it's just not the normal stuff that we all anticipate,
that we all were trained with, but there's also a later variety that seems to kind of either herald the onset
of GVHD or the overlap syndrome that we've all become aware of.
And it's something that either persists and is harder to treat, and so it leads to more complications in most large series.
And so in 2024, as we were ending the year, we looked back and saw an increased incidence of that latitude GVHD.
And so this group wanted, our group wanted to take a look at, was there something that we were doing different?
Was there something that changed? And how can we overcome this issue?
Because it had not been a problem in other years.
And so a retrospective analysis was designed that looked at the patient journey, 281 patients in total,
and with a planned sub-analysis that's yet to be finished of 62 transplants done in 2024,
looking at how did the T-cell kinetics change, or how did the T-cell population change?
Just on regular routine chimerism analyses that we tend to do,
of either CD33 fractions and the CD3 fraction, or an unsorted group with CD3.
And so a rather busy slide to highlight kind of the left lower order onset of GVHD,
defined as "late," meaning no overlap from chronic GVHD whatsoever,
and anything that was after day 100.
Typically, those patients are falling in Utah up until that point.
And then, as you heard from a colleague of mine, Dr. Barron, in a previous discussion,
we have this five shade area that patients are longing to get back to their home that we transplant in.
And so once they go back, the attack tapers that are established by us and by the PharmDs,
whether that's absolutely followed, hit or miss followed, what happens to those patients when they go back?
And so we were able to come up with fairly detailed characteristics of these patients,
but shown very wide ranges of T-cell kinetics, or T-cell measurements, if you will,
between day 100 and day 180, and the shifts that happen thereon.
This led to the identification of about 10, now going up into 12, on further analysis of the data,
and seeing that there was quite severe acute GVHD.
And it was noticeable in the 29 patients that we found that the change in that T-cell kinetics
from day 100 to day 180 seemed to predict a higher incidence of not only mortality, 64% compared to 33%,
but also the organ, which was affected, honestly.
And so, we did a lot of research on that.
We did a lot of research on the T-cell kinetics in those patients,
and we found that there was a very high incidence of T-cell kinetics in those patients.
And so, we did a lot of research on the T-cell kinetics in those patients.
to myeloplate. This is a riskier transplant and is that set to perhaps, we had also done more
peripheral blood rather moving away from marrow just based on the population that we had. Was
that the change that we should be making? And so far, if you look in 2025, which we've done in
preliminary as of so far, we're not seeing the same acute GVH signal and we've had an uptick in
the number of marrows that we have. And so the hope in the future is that we can look at this in
a larger cohort to validate. As I look back in the data and again, a newer person directing the
program at Minnesota, maybe it's just a matter of changing the GVHC regimen. If you look, a large
amount of the myeloplate population that we had in 2024 was still the methotrexate population.
And it's still the methotrexate population. And it's still the methotrexate population.
And it's still the methotrexate population. And it's still the methotrexate population. And it's
still the methotrexate population. And it's still the methotrexate population. And it's still the
methotrexate population. And it's still the methotrexate population. And it's still the methotrexate
population. And it's still the methotrexate population. And it's still the methotrexate population. And it's
still the methotrexate population. And it's still the methotrexate population. And it's actually a lesson that it showed you. You can do this across the different platforms, both reduced intensity and myeloablation. And so we changed that in our program and have now convinced and changed everyone over to post-trial sub-sci. And so perhaps that will be helpful in the future as well.